[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, мене звати Наталія Шон, і
я вітаю вас на уроці англійської мови,
почнемо сьогодні, ми продовжуємо говорити про
школи та освіту, тому давайте почнемо
з тексту, подивіться, це великий
текст про школу  кажучи, що цей текст
від Дарії, і це про школу її мрії,
оскільки ви бачите деякі слова дивовижні, скажімо,
подивіться на текст протягом п'яти секунд і
спробуйте вгадати, яких слів не вистачає, щоб
ви могли сказати мені, яких слів не вистачає,
якщо ви вгадали, так, ймовірно, ви можете  сказати
, що відсутні статті, дозвольте мені написати,
які у нас є статті, ми маємо
a або ми кажемо a an і артикль так
невизначений артикль
зараз не є артиклем і немає статті зараз давайте
прочитаємо текст разом і заповніть
статті Я даю вам дві хвилини на це
[Музика]
добре, перш ніж ми разом перевіримо, дозвольте мені
нагадати вам деякі правила, імовірно,
коли ви переглядаєте правила, ви
можете змінити деякі свої відповіді, тому
давайте почнемо з  невизначений  у статті, і у
мене є питання, чому у нас є група,
і так, ми говорили про це, тому ми
використовуємо невизначений артикль F, коли слово
починається на приголосний, як таблиця,
маркер, телефон, але ми не можемо сказати
Apple для цього  чому ми використовуємо артикль
і яблуко, добре, давайте розглянемо
правила, і перше з них: ми використовуємо
невизначений артикль a або n для позначення
чогось вперше я бачу
таблицю, таблиця велика, і подивіться на мій
приклад тут  ти любиш випити
я вперше говорю про напій
, тому я говорю напій або стіл
давайте рухаємося далі ми використовуємо невизначений артикль
a або an з назвами вакансій привіт мене
звати Наталія я вчитель, ви можете сказати
привіт, мене звуть Дарія, я студентка,
давайте подивимося на мій приклад, тут Джон –
лікар, тому ми використовуємо статтю F, давайте
перейдемо до правила номер три, ми використовуємо
невизначений артикль a або один з одним
оголошеним після слів що
чи таке для  Наприклад, така красива
дівчина або такий інтерес до уроку або
wh  у чудовий день просто пам’ятайте
після слова what і such ми використовуємо артикль
om, а останній ми використовуємо артикль a
om, що означає один, що стосується окремого
об’єкта, особи чи однієї одиниці
вимірювання в цих реченнях, використовуючи один
замість  невизначений артикль
граматично правильний, тому я можу сказати, що я
бачу одну таблицю, і це абсолютно нормально,
якщо я збираюся сказати, що я бачу таблицю,
давайте подивимося на мій приклад тут я б
хотів апельсин і два лимони, будь ласка,
апельсин означає один  апельсин, щоб я міг
замінити це бананом, допоможіть мені так,
я б хотів банан і лимон,
наприклад, один банан, один лимон, добре готово,
тепер давайте переглянемо цю конкретну статтю,
давайте почнемо, щоб тут було більше правил,
давайте, це перше, яке ми використовуємо
стаття там, щоб посилатися на те, про
що вже згадувалося. Я проходив
повз пекарню Бенні, коли
вирішив зайти в пекарню, щоб
отримати хліб або згадати свій приклад
про стіл я бачу стіл, що
стіл великий, це те саме  ле  Переходимо до
номера два, ми використовуємо статтю про те, що, коли
ви масштабуєте, у цьому місці є лише одне з чогось
, навіть якщо воно не
згадувалося раніше, давайте подивимося на
приклад, який ми вчора гуляли в лісі,
щоб ми могли лише одне  ліс, і
коли я кажу ліс, я маю на увазі той
конкретний ліс, який знаходиться дуже близько від
мого місця, або ви можете сказати, що я йду до
магазину, це означає, що я маю на увазі шоу,
яке відбувається
в моєму будинку на першому поверсі, тому  це
конкретне шоу, давайте продовжимо, ми
використовуємо статтю смерть у реченнях або закриттях,
де ви ідентифікуєте конкретну особу
або предмет. Людина, яка написала цю книгу
, відома не просто будь-якою людиною, а людиною,
яка написала цю конкретну книгу,
саме цим чоловіком, тому нам потрібно  щоб
використати статтю там, давайте перейдемо далі, ми
використовуємо статтю, що для позначення унікальних людей або
об’єктів, як приклад,
ви можете піти в будь-яку точку світу, тому у
нас лише один світ, і тому ми
використовуємо статтю вони їхній світ  або
сьогодні я можу побачити  прекрасний місяць
на небі знову місяць і небо
унікальні об'єкти давайте рухаємося далі ми використовуємо
статтю про те, що перед суперлативами та
порядковими числівниками ти
найвищий у нашому класі найвищий і
другий приклад, це третій раз, коли
я дзвоню тобі  сьогодні, тож це
порядковий номер, давайте перейдемо далі ми використовуємо
артикль там з прикметниками для
позначення цілої групи людей давайте подивимося
на приклад, французи люблять сир, я
можу сказати, а японці люблять суші, тому
тут японці та французи не
про  мова людей це
про націю група людей або
я можу сказати українська любов вареники
давайте йти далі
використовувати з десятиліттями наприклад він
народився в 70-х 1970-х кажучи знову
треба використати артикль тут давайте
йти далі  ми використовуємо статтю там із
закриттями, введеними тільки, тому зі
словом only давайте подивимося на приклад,
ви єдина людина, яку він буде слухати,
це єдиний стіл, який я хочу
купити, і останній  скористайтеся статтею
там із назвами географічних областей.
Зворотні гірські хребти групи
островів, канали та океани,
давайте наведемо мені приклад я піду в новий
круїз вниз по Нілу ми багато говорили
про географічні назви на наших
попередніх уроках, чи пам’ятаєте ви, що
були  два уроки про Великобританію та
Україну ми грали в ігри добре, тепер
повернемося до Дарі Айлета так і давайте
перевіримо це, щоб ви могли побачити текст, а зараз
я збираюся прочитати його для вас, скажи, що мене
звати Дарія я восьмий клас  учень, я
хотів би розповісти вам кілька слів про
школу моєї мрії,
давайте розберемо ці три речення, тому
учень восьмого класу я не можу сказати, що
добре, чому добре, тому що слова
вісім починаються з голосної, дозвольте мені
це написати  для вас
так Дар’я учениця восьмого класу ви
бачите слово вісім починається з голосної
, тому ми не можемо використовувати програму для статей,
давайте йти далі я хотів би сказати вам кілька
слів кілька слів це фіксована
фраза a  мало означає, що деякі ми не можемо врятувати
вас, тому що це  змінить
значення речення відтінок означає
недостатньо кілька означає якесь слово, тому було
б правильно сказати кілька тут давайте перейдемо
далі про школу моєї мрії знову
школа моєї мрії
ми вперше говоримо про школу  і ми
маємо багато шкіл, тому
тут нам потрібно використати статтю, давайте
перейдемо до школи, де навчання також
досить добре, але я думаю, що там можна змінити кілька речей,
як ви бачите тут,
ми змінили невизначений артикль air
school моєї  мрійте про школу,
тому що ми продовжуємо говорити про
школу, давайте рухатися далі, перш за все,
школа моєї мрії повинна бути більше ніж і
добре обладнана великими коридорами та
світлими класами, якби я був
директором цієї школи,
я б купив нові стільці та парти  подивіться
на це речення ще раз стільці та парти
ми не маємо артиклі чому добре
ми не вживаємо неозначені артиклі air або
n з формами множини багато стільців ми можемо
сказати F стільці або на партах Браво
давайте також перейдемо до школи  потрібні широкі
слова з маркерами або навіть розумними дошками.
Тут діє те саме правило, ми не використовуємо
невизначений артикль air або n зі словами у множині
вони будуть добре виглядати в класах
розумні дошки надзвичайно корисні для того, щоб
добре стояти без статей, давайте
продовжимо, по-друге, я б  скасувати
домашнє завдання ще раз домашнє завдання
ми не використовуємо тут жодних статей, тому що
ми не говоримо про конкретне
домашнє завдання це домашнє завдання чи це домашнє завдання чи
можемо ми порахувати домашнє завдання один два три
домашні завдання
воно не працює, тому ми не використовуємо
статтю тут  було б краще, якби
діти могли виконувати всі вправи під час
шкільних годин,
а потім були вільними. Я також думаю, що
студенти не повинні носити такі важкі кам'яні
шкарпетки, ви пам'ятайте це після
слова, що ми повинні використовувати статтю,
якраз у такий прекрасний день, але  у нас тут є кам'яні
шкарпетки, ми не можемо сказати, що такі важкі
рок-шкарпетки
це множина, тому ми уникаємо
використання мотики, і вони можуть просто залишити свої
підручники та робочі зошити, наприклад, у шкільній
бібліотеці  У школі моєї мрії
має бути великий ігровий майданчик і
басейн. Я люблю плавати, і я
був би радий мати уроки плавання
замість інших занять на уроці фізкультури
, що стосується їдальні, я б змінив
їжу там і я б
трохи загальмував  довше, щоб діти могли
їсти без поспіху, давайте подивимося на це
речення ще раз, їх кафетерій, їхня
їжа та гальма, ми говоримо
про певний кафетерій у школі, а не
в офісах чи десь у світі,
ми говоримо про це конкретне
місце в цьому конкретному місці  школа те саме
стосується їхньої їжі та гальма,
давайте рухатися далі Я також хотів би
мати більш простору бібліотеку з великою кількістю
цікавих книг і журналів у
школі моєї мрії всі вчителі добрі
розумні та доброзичливі вони
добре ладнають з учнями, я б хотів  частіше ходити зі своїм класом на
різні концерти, виставки
техніки,
і останнє речення це ідея школи моєї
мрії, і вони сподіваються, що хтось
Школи знову стануть кращим місцем для
навчання ідея моєї мрії
це ідея, ми говоримо про цей
конкретний текст, тому ми використовуємо цю
статтю тут, щоб це виглядало як
дуже гарний текст і дуже гарна школа для
тата  мрію зараз я хочу, щоб ви
переглянули текст у класі, щоб у
нас було дві колонки футбольна музика,
плавання, мистецтво зборки зовнішній та танцювальний,
а також друга частина цих
місць, як-от студія, басейн, стадіон, отвір і
корт, я хотів би, щоб ви зрівнялися  ці
дві колонки, наприклад, ви не можете сказати
футбольний басейн правильно, вам потрібно сказати
футбольний стадіон я даю вам 30 секунд
подивіться на слова і спробуйте зіставити їх
добре готовий перевірити давайте підемо, що
знову стосується футболу футбольний
стадіон давайте запишемо це
фантастично як щодо музики гарна музична
студія давайте підемо з басейном
добре, що йде з дивною арт-студією Браво
давайте запишемо це фантастично
як щодо актової зали добре
наші двері допоможіть мені, будь ласка,
добре  y відкритий стадіон
добре, а як щодо танцювальної студії,
яке слово ми не вжили добре, ми не
використовували шнури чи можемо ми сказати футбольний майданчик ні
що ми використали зі словом корт
баскетбольні майданчики давайте запишемо це
фантастично зараз я хочу, щоб ви  маю кілька
завдань на аудіювання для цього я збираюся
подзвонити своєму другові, тому його звуть Джордж
Террелл Яна, він вчитель англійської мови,
і ми збираємося обговорити деякі
класи, деякі кімнати, ми будемо говорити
в основному про школу, тому я хочу, щоб ви  щоб
послухати та запам'ятати інформацію, якою
він збирається поділитися, готовий, як ти
сьогодні, я чудово дякую,
тому ми з Джорджем маємо пару
запитань, відповідаючи на запитання, тому я
знаю, що ви працюєте в школі
вчителем  англійської мови, так, я вважаю, що це
досить великий, скільки у вас кімнат
, скільки у вас студентів,
я цілком впевнений, що більше тисячі,
які кімнати, на вашу думку, це
цікаве питання,
гм, я думаю, що у нас багато важливих кімнат
в нашій школі  по-перше, моя кімната
дуже класна англійська, де навчаються студенти,
але я також вважаю, що інші
кімнати також важливі, як спортзал
або бібліотека з кімнатами інших
предметів так, я цілком погоджуюсь з вами,
приємно мати спортзал, і це приємно мати
басейн і враховуючи, що вони
мають обидва одночасно
добре, ви також згадали бібліотеку, чому
ця бібліотека важлива
о, я думаю, що це дуже важливо, це
місце з усіма знаннями, де ви можете
отримати книгу, ви можете знайти те, що
вам потрібно  а також мають кілька комп'ютерів,
які чекають, знайдіть
необхідну для вас інформацію. Ви
абсолютно праві Я вважаю, що армійське
питання 20% ви в порядку, а як щодо
доступу до Wi-Fi, ви знаєте, щоб студенти
мали C або підключення до Інтернету
ну, можливо, не три для  безкоштовне, але,
можливо, обмежене з'єднання добре, щоб
вони не проводили весь свій час в
Інтернет-серфінгу, і я бачу вашу думку
добре, останнє питання на сьогодні, чи варто
навчати школи різними іграми  сюрприз,
ласощі чи ліжко для стрибків у смартфонах,
як ви думаєте, хм, це
цікаве питання,
я вважаю, що школа повинна мати можливість купити
всі речі, якщо вони можуть, я також
думаю, що розумні дошки, звичайно, дуже
важливі, але я твердо вірю,
що це дійсно добре  вчителі мають багато
продуктивних уроків без будь-якого обладнання,
щоб просто потрапити на борт імаму, дякую
, гарного дня, а також ви купуєте мій
фантастичний вислів. Я хотів би сказати,
що це була дуже цікава розмова,
тепер давайте переглянемо інформацію, скажімо,
чи має він великий  школа чи маленька
добре добре
добре зроблено, що щодо кімнат
більше 100 фантастичних і студентів,
скільки учнів там
100 чи 1000 так більше ніж 1000 учнів
і які кімнати Джордж
вважає важливими так, він згадав,
що його кімната є  дуже важливо, що він
вчитель англійської, звичайно, я,
напевно, також сказав би те саме, що моя
кімната важлива, тому що я важливий
учитель, але він також згадав про вас
ra gym це дуже важливо, і бібліотека
молодець,
чому він вважає, що бібліотеки
важливі так, тому що ми можемо знайти
багато книг, які ми можемо мати, ми можемо знайти
там комп'ютери, і ми можемо знайти
інформацію в Інтернеті. Браво і говорити
про інвестиції, які  школа
має зробити,
чи пам’ятаєте ви дошки чи приладдя,
книги та ігри так, він сказав, що він
не буде складати всі яйця в один
кошик, тому було б добре мати ігри,
приладдя й книги разом із технологією,
але він згадав дуже важливу
інформацію про те, що  вчителеві нічого не
потрібно для уроку, тільки
дошка та маркер, тому під час наступного
уроку ми поговоримо про
вчителів, які особливості є
важливими для вчителів у
школі 21 століття, тому ваше домашнє
завдання – переглянути наступні часи
теперішнє і минуле просте,
теперішнє і минуле досконале наступні уроки
у нас будуть уроки граматики,
а вони Ізабель це означає, що нам
потрібно зупинитися  e урок дуже дякую за те, що ви
приєдналися до мене на цьому уроці, побачимось
наступного разу, до побачення
[Музика]